the Joe Rogan experience yeah Denver
legend you know I'm really glad that all
this [ __ ] has died down with boxing
versus MMA like there's no like you can
like both of them now you know can you
can I deal with all the time because
what I'm doing this isn't a we're safe
you know with it didn't I deal with all
the time especially I can't officially
announce it there's an announcement
coming out Friday show on Showtime but
it does just that it's boxing it's
fighting it's UFC Bellator Showtime like
HBO where there's no there's no agenda
right just a like a variety fun show for
a fight fans Entertainment fans that's
[ __ ] awesome
yeah man I'm excited but I do see that
though boxers yeah like MMA that's why
it doesn't parks yeah that's what gave
me the idea for the show and I pitched
the show because when I was covering the
Conor McGregor stuff I'd have these
boxing heads coming like what are you
talking about man why can't I like get
out of here
stay stay in the cage I'm in May this is
the sweet science I'm like well I like
both though man I'm so close boxer I
like boxing too why's it matter
that's like saying I can't watch the NFL
and watch the NBA what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
okay Bowl they get tribal everybody gets
weird like this is team boxing we're
team MMA it's fun
it's stupid man there was a thing like
that with wrestlers and jiu-jitsu people
yeah man
when instant anyway arm barred Royce
Alger in the UFC and got him in it and
they went ran backstage eating anyway
yells out [ __ ] wrestling it's like how
weird is that it was fun because there
was look there's a lot of [ __ ] talking
going on between all the camps and Royce
Alger who was a top of the food chain
American wrestler they thought he was
just gonna run in and storm the [ __ ]
the UFC and start smashing people and
they even said in that fight he said
it's time to bring in the 18 you know
that's what he said it's like a little
pre-fight thing and instant anyway I was
like yeah you know about arm bars
because I [ __ ] sure do yeah and NSYNC
anima an armbar quick see you can find
that instant anyway versus Royce Alger
it's voice but with an arc this is an
American cat and then he lost to what
was that dude the wolf that dude they
call himself the world
jack
send goddammit great name though the
wolf Jackson those private those tribe
is so weird though man it says reverse
them it's a stupid you don't you don't
have to pick one you know you know I can
DVR the box and fight and watch UFC
fight like yeah and watch all of it but
a completely different they are
completely different there's some things
you can do in boxing that you just
cannot do in MMA you can't get away
there it is it's an anyway Royce Alger
god damn what the hold [ __ ] the guy
that was like bas Rutten on the floor
like the whole deal dude and these these
are the early days so this was in 1997
and I was there that's what is that I
don't know if it was in Denver mats
Denver brother it's 1997 I sure I went
you see in Denver
that's Denver are you sure okay I feel
like it not been 13 J it was the second
UFC that I worked the first one that I
worked was in Dothan Alabama and you
don't remember this one I do not
remember with that one gust oh there you
go so this one is [ __ ] man 97 yeah and
so Royce Alger takes him down
immediately and ensign went on to submit
a lot of guys including he submitted
Randy [ __ ] coat or so stop and think
of this this is a fight at [ __ ] on a
what way through fighting at it's just
200 pounds but and still even then he
had beautiful salt pepper yeah look at
those traps son omiyage Japan 30 no
Jackie was
[Music]
my Japan is 30 then he was already
really experienced he's also real
experience
had a [ __ ] savage mindset look up
jack dancing is Jesus just skip ahead to
the much better writers he was even good
back there how much better is he now
well now he just gets [ __ ] sight back
it up a little bit he gets [ __ ]
psychotic oh my God look at this you got
a bag of that oh you ruined it well
scooted old John Rocker tonight looking
slim look at this and say moving forward
Roy Sal just shoots immediately and take
his back look at the guillotines attempt
here look at this switches it over and
booted no he goes through the other arm
watch this here it is oh this poor guy
has no idea
yep you just didn't know what to do oh
he slipped out of that one and he's got
wrists just risked a pond he doesn't
have anything covers his knuckles Anson
doesn't but algid does so it's smart
Frandsen like if he was gonna get at
other person like yeah these are these
are the days you didn't have to have
anything like Royce is wearing shoes yep
look he's got some [ __ ] wrestling
shoes on remember guys are scared of
wrestling shoes because of heel hooks
you get the grip on the hill yeah that
was a big deal right like if you're
gonna fight in Pride boy you got to be
real careful those [ __ ] he looks
especially if you fighting something
like Josh Barnett erect depending where
you're fighting River doom and pride you
can be in some trouble because here it
is it catches them from here here comes
set it up and seize punching with bare
knuckle to the eyes in the face it's a
totally different field right it's a
different experience completely
different I'm a [ __ ] giant proponent
for bare-knuckle I really think that
should go to bear I just can't why I
never passed that now we're past that
but you're not because the fingers are
all loose look you saw this fight this
weekend with the eye gouges yeah let's
talk about that look at this whoa there
goes baby oh that's the extension here
idea how to get out of you there this is
right here this is [ __ ] bill that's a
long finish a flap superfox bill that's
it that's a [ __ ] up arms pirate broken
probably broken yeah that's intense rich
Act is that jacked
why not he's armed art and Randy [ __ ]
KOTOR baculum day yeah I remember when
he threw these nasty leg kicks from the
butt scoot position
so first time ever saw somebody throw
real good leg kicks from the buttons
boot audition gypsy that I'm standing
over him yeah but dude he would skip
forward on his hand and slam that leg
like real power in the leg kicks like
dangerous leg kicks but not thrusts like
radical kicks yeah he would like but
scoot forward and a roundhouse kick him
in the legs it's like whoa this is
dangerous
[Applause]